hi guys I got a question about nuts and seeds on
a ketogenic diet they're totally okay to do but
let me just kind of cover some points about it
pecans are really fatty and those are real good
nut to consume on this eating plan macadamia
nuts are even better because they're more fat
the thing is about macadamia nuts so sometimes
they go rancid so you have to make sure that you
get them fresh walnuts too can go rancid make
sure that the fresh not the ones that you buy
in the bin that sit there for like six months
cashews are a bit high in carbohydrate so if
you're going to consume those do smaller amounts
but they're very sweet and they're very easy and
addictive to keep eating especially around the
holidays the problem is keeping them in bowls
around your house everywhere you go at night
you're like tempted or watching other people
eating them it's like not good I had a person's
just recently made a comment I thought it was
kind of funny they said it's not about watching
your diets but watching other people's diet it's
like wow that's just ten ten things okay let's
talk about the nut butters like peanut butter
make sure on the label it does not have added
sugar hydrogenated oils you just want sea salt
and peanuts that's it or sea salt and almonds
that's it because they put so much other stuff
in there and you want to make sure that the actual
penis doesn't have added monosodium glutamate or
modified food starts they add that in there to
make the peanuts or the mixed nuts tastes better
I'm going to recommend you because it's really
easy to overdo nuts and irritate the gall bladder
especially if the nut is raw because it has phytic
acid which tends to irritate the gall bladder and
cause right shoulder pain two to three ounces
in a given meal that's what you want to stick
with trying to go more than that especially
if you have a gallbladder issue and then we
have the seeds seeds are high in nutrients high
in healthy fats low in carb seeds are actually
even better than the nuts stars nutrient wise
you have the sunflower seeds the hemp seeds
chia seeds flax seeds you can make crackers with
them we're going to put our recipe on cracker
you can put them on salads you can make a trail
mix there's so many different ways you can even
there's even a recipe you can make a kind of a
rice out of hemp but anyway these are okay these
are the guidelines and put your comments below
hi guys hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually analyzes
your symptoms to find the cause the root cause of
all of your symptoms the most likely cause so
take the quiz now and we'll send you report